hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I'm going to talk
about one of my favorite tools that I
use all the time to run my business it's
called odesk and it allows me to
outsource a lot of the work that I don't
want to do to people around the world
who do you want to do it lets me focus
on higher priority task for my business
so i'm going to show you here this is my
page of my favorite tools that i used to
run my business and will scroll down and
we'll find odesk there it is so click on
that load it up and i'll tell you a
little bit about it and also how I use
it to grow my business so these are
basically a list of all sorts of people
around the world who are looking for
contract work and want to be outsourced
workers so they're never going to come
into your office you don't ever have to
worry about having staff sitting next to
you they're used to working overseas
remotely from their computer and ODIs
facilitates you being able to work with
them so you can post a job and go
through all the details of what your job
is about and who you need and what
you'll find is that people start bidding
on it and you can show all sorts of
different categories and pick the one
that best fits what you're looking for
so if you need a web designer you need
some sales and marketing support you
need so I'm going to do some bookkeeping
for you it's all there let's pick the
data entry so I need somebody to help me
with data entry for my business for
example all that stuff you don't want to
do you can hire somebody who oversees to
do it for you what you'll see is a list
of contractors that come up so there's a
hundred and sixty-two thousand
contractors who wanted to data entry for
you this is fantastic what you'll see is
a list of who they are so you see their
names is this is Kathy you'll see her
picture you'll see how many stars she's
received so just like eBay people
receive feedback from previous job so
she has 4.8 stars on average received
seven feet back you'll see what her
wages how many hours she's worked on
odesk where she's from testa she's
passed so the tests are really important
what this basically allows them to do is
they can take tests in different areas
so they can say take a England it could
take you know how to communicate via
email test
this is for data entry they could take a
Microsoft Office test that that's
important for you and also test for
other things that you may need to hire
somebody for so if you're hiring a
programmer you might want to make sure
they've passed the PHP MySQL programming
test and you may not have any idea if
they're any good or not so that's a
great way to find out if somebody really
has the skills or not and she has a
portfolio here by oh I like I like this
part here I like seeing the picture are
usually hire people who have a picture
so this person who would hire or if you
see someone who has a non-professional
picture wouldn't hire them but we have
way too many contractors so what you can
do is start to narrow down by different
fields that might interest you so for
example here on the right side this lets
you break it down a little bit more so
you can say I only want people who have
received four and a half to five star
feedback from previous jobs so that
narrows it down then you can say you
know how much do I want to pay well
maybe for data entry my max is say ten
dollars an hour so that again will start
narrowing it down a lot you can look at
tests and so this will basically allow
them to take tests that will rank them
against all the other people on odesk so
from those 160,000 people on odesk
wanted to entry they can all take
different tests and ODIs will basically
rank them for you which saves you a ton
of time so you can say I want somebody
who scored say in the top 10% on US
English basic and English spelling test
that's important for my data entry job
and maybe English is really important
than maybe it's not just depends on the
on the skill that you need them to have
so you can say maybe I need windows XP
email etiquette whatever it is you can
keep going down you know location I
don't care where they're located you
might prefer to have somebody native to
North America if it's a communications
type of role where they're going to be
speaking with clients or emailing with
clients for data entry stuff i usually
don't really care where they are because
as long as we can communicate that seems
to be okay and then we can go and
basically what we've narrowed it down to
so now it's you know 2,000 people still
who can potentially apply for these jobs
you can see that with four dollars an
hour if you
an hour eight dollars an hour and you
know if you want you can narrow it down
even more from there but it's a great
option to find people who are interested
in working doing the kind of tasks that
you're not interested in doing or maybe
the the less important task so you can
focus on the CEO tasks to help you grow
your business they want to work they're
used to working remotely and Odessa
helps you manage the entire process so
you can post a job people will start to
apply you'll start seeing you know the
pictures and profiles of all the people
who have applied you can then ask them
interview questions you can ask them to
take tests you can even offer a simple
trial job if you like to start testing
people out and then hopefully you find
somebody who you like working with now
that's how you kind of go about getting
somebody working with them is also
really easy and oh does does a good job
of helping people out on that side as an
employer so i thought i would show you
on my end what I see as an employer that
really helps so I'll look at somebody
here I've hired this person 13 days ago
and what it'll do is it'll show you
their profile and I'll tell you how much
they've worked for me so here you know
this week they've worked two hours to me
last week was almost three hours I'm
paying three dollars and thirty-three
cents an hour and what odesk will do is
whenever somebody starts working for you
they have to log into the system to say
i'm working for evan now and it starts
tracking their time a node s will take a
ten percent commission from the odesk
worker on top of the salary so that you
know three dollars and thirty-three
cents an hour ten percent of it goes to
0 desk and the rest goes to the
contractor so it allows you to keep
track of how much time exactly there is
being spent on your particular tasks you
can CR see here that I've limited the
time to 5 hours per week so you can set
a limit saying I don't want them working
the more than a certain number of hours
and the budget you know kind of explodes
on you and what you can also do I never
really do this but you can check out the
work diary and if you want to
micromanage or especially at the
beginning if you want to see how they're
doing what they're working on for you
what this does is it take
screenshots of their computers as they
start working for you and they know this
isn't you know Big Brother kind of
watching it without them knowing they
know that as soon as they login to walk
to start working for me it'll start
keeping track at a time and also start
recording what they're working on so
this person is doing some data entry for
me so they don't some of the stuff
involves Twitter so they'll be on I can
see what screenshots are doing here
they're on Twitter and you can see that
their various screenshots show what
they're doing it shows you the time and
underneath here it shows you how active
they were so if it's you know full green
means like that they've been working a
lot they've taking a lot of keys
keyboard strokes and they've moved the
mouse around a lot so they're active if
they're not just kind of sitting on that
page you're not doing anything and you
can see that most of the time my worker
here has been pretty active so that's
great for me no surprises so here it
kind of shows you if they're kind of
mucking around on facebook or doing
other things or if they're actually
working for your project so I think it's
a great way to find people who are
working for you potentially there
they've got the skills that allows it
outsource almost all the tasks with your
business allows you to screen them
really easily find people who have good
feedback we've passed the tests that are
needed to do that task you can hire them
on trial projects if you want to see who
works fast and then hire somebody for
your main project and then once you do
hire them it allows you to track their
time it's great for you great for them
you don't have to worry about payroll
everything goes through odesk and if you
like you can see exactly how many hours
I've worked you put a cap on it and you
can see what they're working on and how
many you know keyboard strokes are
taking make sure that they're actually
doing the stuff that you've hired them
to do so overall I think it's been a
really great service I've hire people on
here to do video editing for me to do
data entry for me to be personal
assistants for me and every time I think
I really need help to grow my business I
go back on odesk and post a new job and
find new people to help me take that up
to the next level for the most part
they're very professional they're trying
to
Oh their own little independent business
as well they're trying to get good
ratings they want to get more business
and so it ends up working out really
well and a great way to find great
workers at pretty good prices and let
you focus on the most important CEO
tasks to help you get that business to
the next level so I hope you guys
enjoyed how I use odesk and encourage
you to check it out if you did like the
video or if you have any questions
please leave a comment below I'd also
appreciate any thumbs up you want to
leave on the video and stay tuned for
next episode